anything happened in the news yesterday
was there I don't know I was sort of
scrolling through and oh yes I saw the
Alex Jones interview
heard round the world I had a lot of
work that I was supposed to do yesterday
could not do any of it because I like so
many people was glued to my screen I
didn't even at first know where to find
this Alex Jones Show I just was blowing
up all of her social media Kanye West is
on Alex Jones saying all sorts of crazy
things and I so I found the link I think
on rumble or something
Kanye in his own words
I see good things about Hitler also the
Jew I love everyone and Jewish people
are not going to tell me you can love
um
you know us and you can love what we're
doing to you with the contracts and you
can love what we're you know what we're
pushing with the pornography but this
guy that
invented highways invented the very
microphone that I use as a musician you
can't say out loud that this person ever
did anything good and I'm done with that
I'm done with the classifications every
human being has something of value that
they brought to the table especially
Hitler how about that one Ari Emmanuel
how you like that one Hey Ron you're
going to do anything to fix Chicago even
like our truth the fact that African
Americans were in America before the
Pilgrims that truth is hidden that we
are actually the Native Americans or
some of us are native
so a couple of fact checks here uh the
black people were not in America before
the Pilgrims and are not they are not
the the Native Americans the real Native
Americans and also you you do not in
fact have to hand it to Hitler
you never actually have to hand it to
Hitler and this for those who are just
listening right now
and can't see it Kanye is wearing this
full kind of [ __ ]
suit and head mask thing so you can't
see his face throughout the interview
Alex Jones keeps saying is this really
even Kanye I'm talking to you it's an
amazing thing to watch Alex Jones be
made uncomfortable in an interview
because he he comes out and he says you
know well all those people are calling
you a Nazi and but you're not a Nazi and
Kanye says well sir you know so it
that was very very jarring it's why
everyone tuned in in the first place but
then
Kanye complicates
his Declaration of love for the Nazis by
declaring love for all sorts of other
people
I love the Zionist I love the people
that that blocked my bank account
because God runs the world and uses
everyone I do love Hitler I do love the
zionists I love everyone I love Jewish
people I love Jewish we're talking about
Stanley Kubrick but Jesus is King and I
love everyone this is Love Speech Ari
this is Love's speech in Jesus name the
real king of Israel Jesus Christ this is
lust feature I love Jewish people
I love
supermodels I love everyone accordingly
from all the way from the balenciagas to
the Hitler's let me tell you a story
hold on Sir to Arya Manuel to Jamie
Diamond to the people who I love all of
those you love Mao Zedong absolutely
clarify that you're saying you're like
christ-like you love everybody yeah you
love Jim Jones you love Jeffrey Dahmer
absolutely everything okay well let's
clarify
so you would assume that when someone
says I love Hitler and I love the Nazis
that would be followed by and I hate the
Jews but Kanye follows it here by I love
the Jews I love the zionists I love
supermodels I love Mao Zedong I love Ari
Emmanuel I love Stalin I Love Lamp I
don't know I love I love all of these
things
but then he goes on and does seem to
have a special sort of ire for the Jews
and this is what led into
another episode of this three hour long
interview
that went viral as well when Kanye
pulled out an aquarium net and a bottle
of Yoo-hoo to do a sort of Carrot Top
prop comedy routine about
uh the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
net net and Yoo-hoo
what we did is we brought Netanyahu with
us
I'm in the Twilight Zone right now
Netanyahu what do you have to say what
do you have to say to Alex Jones right
now Nick Fuentes and yay
it was bad it was bad attracting me
okay
I had no idea your voice is going to
sound like that Netanyahu
so you don't like Benjamin yet Yahoo
you get it it's a net and Yoo-hoo
and he's sitting there with Nick Fuentes
who is working on his campaign and who
was at that Trump dinner and caused all
the big stir and then
then however the interview took another
turn and specifically on the whole net
net and Yoo-hoo bit he takes it in this
very personal Direction
if I say something that's provocative
towards the Mossad is that misogynistic
hold on let's hear from netany
thanks a lot netting
back to you Alex uh please turn your
phone microphone around sir
I mean I'm definitely overwhelmed here
right now um infowars.com tomorrow's
news today
um listen all I'm trying to get through
here is I believe every group should be
scratch his name to netten I dropped the
uh the Yahoo so we didn't have to I was
tired of picking up the Yahoo and The
netting so for now is just natin I know
some people call him Bibi no some of you
call them yeah yeah but we're gonna call
him netten
what you want man hey yay right after
this I'm gonna sell you crazy I'm gonna
take your family away from you we're not
done with you yet you cannot cause free
thought we have to control the history
books we have to control the banks and
we have to go and kill people also we're
in the better very high
so
at this point in the interview if you're
still watching you're starting to think
okay
something's gone even more off the rails
here than at other times in yay's public
career and then he takes it
all the way personal so it starts out
with Hitler and the Jews then it goes I
love everybody I love I love lamp I love
you know all the I love the Jews I don't
it's not just that I love Hitler I love
the Jews but really I don't like
Benjamin Netanyahu and Israel and but
really this is all about this personal
stuff my family my kids
my life and then and then he kind of
ditches the BB Netanyahu thing and just
gets right into his his personal family
problems
my security is the fact that I didn't
load up pornography last night and I
said this addiction is going to have to
flee from me you know this addiction
since I was five years old that is
destroyed my my mom and my dad's family
that destroyed my family like when I
take full accountability for the
destruction like of my marriage when I
when I I'll point at the Liberals and
say you took my wife from me you know
what took my life for me the fact that I
was married to this beautiful person but
it I felt like it wasn't enough I felt
like I still needed to look at
pornography in some way I'd say to her
well stop making these images stop
breaking the internet you know that
original term comes from my ex-wife
actually having a nude photo that I
didn't know about that someone used her
and put her on a magazine but there's
somewhere where she's like well if my
husband is looking at this I still want
to be like the girls that are doing this
and this becomes people reliving the
traumas pushing the addiction
so so this was the most amazing part of
the interview and nobody's talking about
it because he says look I blame the
Liberals for breaking up my family but
it wasn't the Liberals it was me but
Kanye doesn't blame the Liberals he
blames the Jews in other places for the
zionists or the whoever for breaking up
his family or Benjamin not Yahoo is
going to come and take his family but
then in this moment probably the most
Lucid moment of the interview he says
but it wasn't them
meaning the Liberals are or elsewhere he
said it's the Jews or what it was me it
was me because I looked at pornography
and I did it and and so I lost my family
there are three
defining struggles in Kanye West's
public career that we've seen the first
one is mental disorder meaning he's just
his mind just gets disordered and you
see he's talking about how black people
were here before the Native Americans or
something right you know among all the
other things he said he just said things
that are just so manifestly incoherent
and and uh
obviously not true
then there's performance art Kanye West
has always been this wild performance
artist George Bush doesn't like black
people Taylor Swift I'm going to take
your award from you and I'm not I'll let
you finish but Beyonce had the better
album you got to give this album to
Beyonce then he goes a step further he
says slavery was a choice right one of
the most shocking and offensive things
you can possibly say then he took it up
another level
when he put the Maga hat on wearing that
Maga hat which this was after the
media had called Trump the devil for
however long he says so that's the most
offensive provocative thing I can
possibly do you tell me I can't do it
that's what I'm going to do and then he
took it to its absolute perfect extreme
by saying I like Hitler I like Hitler is
the most shocking and offensive thing
you can possibly say in our culture
Hitler is synonymous with the devil in
our language that it's why he didn't get
the same reaction he says I love now I
love Stalin people can get away with
saying I love Mao I love Stalin well you
can hand it to them you can wear a shake
of orange or whatever
in our language Hitler is synonymous
with the devil in fact worse than the
devil because Hitler was incarnate the
devil's just a spirit Hitler was
incarnate and so you you see even taking
aside maybe Kanye hates the Jews maybe
Kanye is a Nazi whatever you just see
that as the extreme manifestation of
that kind of performance art and then
the third one which no one's talking
about is this guy just lost his whole
family and if you've ever known someone
who's gone through a divorce they go
kind of crazy most of the time and
especially if they've already got these
sort of underlying mental issues and
these underlying artistic issues where
you you were naturally drawn to these
extremes when something like that
happens people can just break and so
it's why I'm not going to make fun of
Kanye West it's why I'm not even going
to really engage too seriously in any of
the claims he's making whether it's
about you know Hitler or the black
Native Americans or Bibi Netanyahu I
mean when he was laughing manically with
the Yoo-hoo in one hand and the the net
in another
I just think it's a really cheap shot to
make fun of somebody or to castigate
somebody you know too too seriously and
he was just kicked off of Twitter
because he posted a star of David with a
swastika in the middle and people are
assuming this is just another
Declaration of his love for the Nazis
it's actually not that's a symbol of
What's called the realism movement
the raelian movement was this movement
from the 1970s
founded by a guy named Claude vorhillon
and I'll see if I yeah here so the
symbol is this this little pendant that
they would wear of the Star of David
with the the swastik in the middle but
it's this idea it's this kind of crazy
cult that believes that uh there are all
these aliens and that you get abducted
by aliens and that uh the word El hoim
Elohim you know the word for God is a
plural term which means those who came
from the sky and they would they would
wear these sort of extraterrestrial
symbols so anyway it's just obviously
all the symbol of disorder and what
should one do
one should
pray for Kanye probably not uh you know
probably not take this stuff
all that seriously I don't I don't think
he should be going on like TV to be
pontificating on these views he
he's always had those three problems
even the personal issues in his life
because he's he's cycled through so many
advisors constantly I personally am
friends with like three of communist
advisors going back 10 years and I don't
know Kanye West I've never met Kanye
West and so you think there are all
these these personal relationships he
lashed out in that interview against
Dave Chappelle for doing a comedy bit
about him Dave Chappelle was defending
Kanye in the comedy bit you know it's
just
if any one of these issues were going
off at a particular time it would be
dangerous but you've got the mental
disorder and you've got the performance
art and you've got the personal life all
kind of crashing around and so I say
probably should should pray for the guy
that's what I would do make sure you
head on over to the member block we also
have fake headlines I need your help in
in Discerning which headlines are real
so if you are not a member click the
link in that description and join us
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]